and the indian variant the prime
minister said that he's anxious
about it but is still pushing ahead with
relaxing restrictions is that
wise well we are
clearly um moving at
speed and scale with the vaccination
program and that is
uh one of the uh it's the number one
test in fact
in the four tests that we apply um we
are vaccinating
uh a scale we're about to to reach about
56 million doses
um delivered almost 36 million people
uh with the protection of first dose but
there are concerns uh in areas like
bolton
and formby and of course past london
that
the b1617.2
variant which was uh initially
identified in
india uh could be more infectious we've
seen infection rates rise by
well from 520 last week to 1313
this week hence why the surge testing
and enhanced tracing is taking place
eight hundred thousand pcr tests have
gone out
15 areas in england but we think that
the road map for monday
remains uh in place because the
vaccines are delivering and vaccines are
keeping
people out of hospital and of course
away from severe infections so
we're confident of that and then of
course we'll continue to monitor because
the reason for the four weeks plus one
the five-week interval
between each step is important to be
able to look at this data
and we will continue to be guided by the
clinicians by the
data as we have done with this
announcement
last night of the additional uh surge
testing 100 nurses directors of public
health
environmental health practitioners going
into
bolton to make sure that we test at
scale
genome sequence and isolate and what
people can really do
for us to break this cycle of
transmission with this new variant
is if you are uh uh we're found to have
the
the uh virus whether symptomatic or
asymptomatic to isolate
as quickly as possible and of course to
make sure you get tested
and come forward for your jab when
you're eligible uh professor christina
pagel from
independent sage says that monday should
be delayed as the fourth test for
relaxing restrictions
hasn't been met um are you taking that
advice on board yours saying that it's
going ahead with the restrictions being
relaxed on monday
well i just outlined the first of those
four tests which is that vaccine
deployment remains at scale and that is
continuing
um of course vaccine effectiveness
remains in place that is also a big tick
this new variant doesn't seem to uh
at the moment we have no evidence that
it escapes the vaccines
or is more severe in uh its impact
on people disregarding sorry to
interrupt your disregarding the advice
uh to to delay opening up on monday
well as i said um the the four tests for
monday have been met we continuously
monitor the situation the clinicians
uh meet regularly the prime minister's
briefed on this
daily to monitor and look at the data
the reason
that the prime minister announced the
four weeks plus one so four weeks of
data collection
and then that final week to make sure
everything is is
you know in place and all the tests are
being met before we open up
was met for the monday opening uh
now we've got another uh period of four
weeks plus one
before we get to 21st of june um and
we'll continue to monitor that
part of our getting back our lives
is scale vaccination and the ability to
surge
test by postcode to then genome sequence
those positive tests
and isolate and as i say you know we
need to do both things at the same time
to be able to meet our roadmap to
reopening the whole of the economy and
getting our lives back but we take those
tests very seriously and of course one
of them is the test on variance
which you've just um asked me about and
that is why today
we are having this this surge in our
ability to um
test people door-to-door make sure we we
give them the most the pcr test but also
they can take advantage of the lateral
flow test you know these lateral flow
tests
are amazing they you do them twice a
week and as long
as you're negative uh that's great once
you're positive you do your pcr
test uh and that's how we overcome this
virus we
keep it under control and then get our
lives back
are we likely to see local lockdowns do
you still see that
as an effective means of containing
the virus well as the prime's set up in
the roadmap
the four tests are the important uh
measure so vaccine deployment vaccine
effectiveness
the keeping infections under control
today
is very much part of that actually
bearing down on infections because
the virus will attempt to mutate and
survive
and and by infecting more people and
then of course keeping eye on variance
we rule nothing out in terms of uh you
know whatever action we need to take
regionally or nationally um we will take
whether it's
flexing the vaccine program as you were
describing in your introduction to this
piece we will
rule nothing out to make sure that we
bear down on this virus
and get our lives back according to the
roadmap
and how is bringing forward the jobs of
10 million people
so decreasing that 12-week gap between
vaccinations how is that
going to help would it not be more
useful to look at
vaccinating younger people who might be
transmitting
the disease more so
again really important question the
clinicians will
look at all of this to see how we can
flex
the vaccination program uh to make it as
effective as possible to deal with this
surge in this uh variant the b1617.2
um they they will make those decisions
and we will be ready to
then implement whether it's vaccinating
uh younger cohorts we've been doing some
work
uh on multi-generational households
where we vaccinate the whole household
over 18s and of course the older groups
who are already eligible
or uh bringing forward the second days
we'll look at
all of that and be guided by the
clinicians as to what we
do on that the important thing to
remember is we've been vaccinating
at scale and when you get the call when
you get the text message we've just
opened to the 38
and 39 year olds then please come
forward and we've also made those
vaccine doses available to of course
bolton uh where they're seeing that
uh that spike in infections uh at the
moment
and those that are uh vaccinated um
sooner than the the 12-week recommended
period of time which we're now told is
most effective for pfizer
will they have less protection
so again in terms of uh what the
clinicians think we should
do uh if you go back to when we started
vaccinating
on the 8th of december the most
vulnerable so
residents of care homes the elderly
residents care homes the over 80s over
75s over 70s
and those clinically extremely
vulnerable that 15 million that we did
by mid-february
have already clearly got their second
dose
as well because we're touching almost 19
million second doses
it's whether the clinicians think we
need to protect
more people um groups
five six seven eight and nine in that
first phase
more rapidly or we should flex the
vaccine program
in a different way but we're ready to
look at all those options
but we'll be guided by the the science
the the clinicians will make those
decisions the important thing is
actually the way you deal with this and
we've seen it happen we've done it in in
parts of london uh in the past few weeks
where you
search test by postcode you genome
sequence so you know
what the numbers are per variant and
then of course you self-isolate so the
the thing that people can help us with
is get your you know twice a week
lateral flow test
if it's positive get your pcr test for
free
um and then isolate isolate isolate
really important okay it's a second day
of eid today and i know many families
clearly want to celebrate rightly so
after the month of ramadan
but just be careful follow the rules do
it outdoors in two family settings
next week next monday uh be careful when
you
also socially interact uh just very
quickly i wanted to ask you about the uh
green cell inquiry
and david cameron being accused not so
much of lobbying as stalking ministers
you were one of the ministers that he uh
lobbied
do you think that his reputation is now
in tatters as it's been described has he
brought the office of prime minister
into disrepute
well i think david cameron did the right
thing to um
come before two select committees
yesterday
and to uh be open and transparent about
his
uh dealings with government with
ministers he himself has already
uh reflected on this and thought
actually uh yes it was a
you know in the eye of a storm if i can
describe it as that
during the uh covert pandemic last year
uh uh that he uh engaged with ministers
and maybe
as he quite rightly reflected uh he
should have just done it in the
as yeah he still hasn't been completely
open we didn't want to disclose
how much he earned sorry
i didn't catch your question uh he still
hasn't been completely open he didn't
want to disclose how much he earned
well he did say that that um he earned
a substantial amount of money much
greater than he would have been paid
as prime minister he also uh you know
made all
his um communications public and he
you know subjected himself to the
scrutiny of the select committees and
promise to come back as well if they
have
additional questions i think just very
quickly because we're out of time
has his reputation been damaged yes or
no
well i think look you know clearly this
is this was a painful period for him and
as he said yesterday
it cannot be easy uh for a prime
minister to go
through this this is a a a yes
well it's a difficult time for him and
and you know i think we should respect
that a little bit as well